you
we just don't know a way to work at
Langley NASA we do a great deal of the
calculator getting our rockets into
space
oh yes yes office NASA awesome
that is a scene from the 2016 film
hidden figures about three
african-american mathematicians whose
efforts ultimately help put men on the
moon
for decades they receive little
recognition for their contributions to
the space program but yesterday NASA
acknowledged their role it renamed a
block in front of its headquarters
hidden figures way to honor women whose
work helped launch rockets math is
always dependable for you it is
America's triumph in the space race was
made possible by people the country
didn't see women many of them
african-american hired by NASA to hand
calculate propulsion lift thrust and
trajectory among them Catherine Johnson
Dorothy Vaughan and Mary Jackson
Margolies shedder Lee's book hidden
figures inspired the oscar-nominated
film it's not a first or an only story
it's a story of a group of women who
were given a chance and who performed
and who opened doors for the women who
came behind them in 1969 Johnson helped
the Apollo mission land on the moon in
2016 she told our Jan Crawford she got
the courage from her father's motto and
you took that to heart
you know better Wednesday NASA formally
recognized these women by naming the 300
block of East Street Southwest in front
of NASA headquarters hidden figures way
most of all hidden figures is about
taking off our blinders and recognizing
the contributions of the unseen
individuals joy lit hi Lick is Johnson's
oldest daughter she always I think
looked beyond any adversity that she
came upon for the goal of seeking a
solution to a problem might have been
nice to have three streets renamed for
the three women yes that's what I think
they named the street for a movie I'd
like to see them name it for the women
next
well said but hidden no more and in some
respects yeah